in this lecture I have three general
areas I want to cover the first is to
consider what needs to be done with
First Amendment jurisprudence in light
of contemporary conditions to adapt it
and make it better for the future in
this context I also want to talk a bit
about what I think is fairly obvious
namely the fact that we appear to have
entered another period of grave
intolerance and we need to consider the
implications for free speech and Free
Press
the second area involves the newest
technology of communication namely the
internet and its component elements
there is an enormous amount of attention
now being devoted to the problems
arising out of social media platforms
and search engines and I would like to
offer some observations on how we might
frame those debates the third area
concerns the phenomenon of globalization
and how we should be thinking about
freedom of speech and press in this
moment where the world as we know it is
being transformed without question the
peoples of the world are becoming more
interconnected and more interdependent
which is the result of many powerful
forces economic technological especially
with communications as well as by the
incredible incredibly powerful Drive of
human curiosity and the impulse for
improving one's life all of which is
easier to fulfill than ever before
issues and problems generated by these
forces of globalization as well as those
that arise out of the actions of
individual nations with consequences and
effects on the global public Commons
require some form of global collective
action yet has as has been widely noted
the institutions that were the public
goods needed to cope with this seemingly
irreversible process of integration and
its attendant issues lagged far behind
nevertheless despite the weakness of
existing international institutions of
governance there are still ways in which
global decisions are being taken as has
now been shown by the Paris agreement on
climate change all of this means that we
now have to conceive of something quite
new namely a global public forum in
which issues can be addressed and
knowledge pursued clearly the most
recent and manifest component of the new
public global public forum is the
Internet
this new communications technology both
contributes to the globalization
phenomena and provides the means of
addressing its issues but there is a
lack of agreement in the world about
what norms of free speech and press
should apply to this new medium and that
means that its usefulness as a public
forum will be impaired unless we take
action
since now effectively censorship
anywhere is censorship everywhere this
is true both in the sense that though I
may live in a country that recognizes my
right to say something whatever I say
there will instantly be published
globally and I may be censored or
chilled from speaking by laws in other
nations that forbid my speech and in the
further sense that censorship and other
nations will stop speakers there from
speaking speakers whom I may want to and
need to hear from in this century
sorting all of this out will be a
defining problem and central to the
shape of our lives but establishing
norms of openness is not the only thing
to be done the theme of knowledge
production whatever one calls it I have
spoken about also has a critical role to
be in a more interdependent world the
system of institutions devoted to the
development of knowledge we have built
up mainly with universities
must also be preserved and protected as
an international forum for the exchange
of ideas as I look at the jurisprudence
and experiences of the First Amendment
over the past century and think about
what should be done now there are
several changes I would make the most
important of course as I suggested in
the preceding talk is to expand the
vision underline the first amendment but
here are several more specific revisions
from my perspective it is a pity that
the court did not bring the same
enthusiasm to the idea of a public and
press right of access to information
that it did to expanding the protection
of expression against various forms of
censorship the key decisions mostly in
the 1970s were narrowly decided by a
simple majority of Justices than they
reflected almost a kind of weariness
from the heady expansion of rights that
occurred in the preceding decade to be
sure conceiving of a robust right of
access requires living with an
incredible array of fact-specific
situations where the government needs
for secrecy very enormous lis in
strength as does the public interest in
knowing what is going on it is
reasonable to fear a flood of cases it
is also probably requires some
differentiation between the rights of
the quote press and of others which
makes many nervous and especially so now
when anyone it seems can claim to be a
journalist which makes drawing that line
more elusive than it was before still in
this one area the United States has been
far less venturesome than many other
nations where the right idea of a right
of access to information has flourished
at the very least that would be good if
the court were to take some cases where
the public's interest is strong and the
government's interest weak and to invoke
the First Amendment
this would help to change the calculus
more towards openness and as a general
proposition that would be all to the
good in my view then there is the
horizontal dimension I mentioned earlier
here the extension
of First Amendment protection to
extremist speech advocacy of illegal
acts hate speech and so on continues to
be very controversial see for example
the essay by Catherine MacKinnon in the
free speech century in my earlier
remarks I made what I believe is a
stronger case for this interpretation of
the First Amendment then the typical
rationales offered which tend to point
to the problems of drawing lines between
acceptable and unacceptable ideas and of
a needing to avoid creating
opportunities for government's judges
and juries simply to use any exception
created in order to suppress on popular
speech I have never been persuaded by
either of John Stuart Mill's arguments
in on Liberty that such speech should be
not be censored because it might be true
or because even if not true we acquire a
livelier sense of the truth by
confronting falsehoods in general I see
this as an admirable effort that is
protection of extremists speech in
America to come to terms with bad
impulses revealed in the act of
censorship as I said earlier as I think
people like Holmes and Brandeis saw
which is why I think we feel actually a
sense of pride not just reluctant
acquiescence in extending protections
this far but I also see this idea of
extending our societal capacities for
tolerance as ultimately dependent on the
presence of distinctive social
conditions that make that meaning
possible in other words it has always
struck me as important that in every
case where extremist speech is protected
the courts in their opinions have made
it perfectly clear that the ideas being
protected are bad which is also always
reinforced by similar pronouncements by
other leaders in the society this is one
key reason why it was so shocking and
potentially consequential for freedom of
speech
when President Trump said of the march
in Charlottesville Virginia by white
supremacists and neo-nazis that there
were quote very
people quote in those groups this
remarkable statement sent shockwaves
through the society bringing added
denunciations of the speakers and of the
president's comment but the president's
statement along with many others like it
have put in doubt how the society is
thinking about evil ideas which then has
potential consequences for what
tolerance and protection of the speech
actually means the larger point here is
that we have to see the application of
free speech to bad and dangerous ideas
as linked to the ways in which the
private sphere is thinking and
interacting with these ideas this is why
for example a neo-nazi march in Skokie
Illinois is a very different matter from
one in Munich Germany where for obvious
reasons the significance of protection
is fundamentally different and why
because of that Germany has chosen a
different path with respect to Nazi
speech the scope of free speech at least
at the extremes is dependent on how it
will interact with what is condoned or
condemned in the private sphere there
are some areas of jurisprudence that
will require a substantial revision in
light of new conditions perhaps the most
noteworthy is the Pentagon Papers case I
have already described its unique and
pragmatic resolution of an eternal and
perplexing problem of government secrecy
versus public knowledge but there are
now three changes in the world that make
this arguably wise resolution
problematic each of which has to do with
developments I will focus on in a moment
namely new communications technologies
and globalization these are one the rise
of new players who are likely to gain
access to government secrets who have
little or no interest in drawing a
responsible balance between the
competing interests involved and I'm
think
in here of Julian Assange and WikiLeaks
second change is the ability of leakers
disseminate exponentially greater
quantities of government secrets secrets
which they cannot possibly vet in making
a decision whether theft and publication
will enhance the public good
Snowden issued hundreds of thousands of
documents and three the increase in the
government's capacity to identify and
then prosecute leakers because of the
ability to trace leaks now through a
myriad forms of communication utilising
texts and emails phone calls and other
conversations this last change the fact
that leakers are now easier to catch
cuts in favor of expanding the right of
access I mentioned a while ago a moment
ago the first two changes indicate that
we can no longer count on the
professional and I would even say
patriotic judgments of the traditional
press think of Ben Bradley and Katharine
Graham
of the Washington Post at the time of
Pentagon Papers we can no longer count
on their professional and patriotic
judgments to strike the right balance in
what to publish and what not in the
free-speech century in book professor
David Straus discusses this new problem
in his essay keeping secrets for myself
I am in favor of preserving the Pentagon
Papers regime but on a sliding scale of
First Amendment protections that would
depend upon the editorial character and
journalist equality of the institutions
in possession of the classified
information the obvious objection to
this approach is that the courts should
not be drawing distinctions between
responsible and other publishers but I
see no practical alternative given a a
need to counteract what will always be a
problematic reality of excessive
government secrecy and be no meaningful
right of access doctrine at this point
to combat that excessive secrecy beyond
all of these refinements there is the
big question that looms before us
will the first amendment stand up to the
next wave of intolerance and oppression
and what can and should be done to shore
up its 42 I pointed out in the first
lecture how the modern idea of freedom
of speech impressed was largely formed
in the distinctive societal crucible of
the 1960's since that time there has not
been a level of national fear that would
generate the magnitude of intolerance
seen in the eras of World War one and
its aftermath and of McCarthyism in the
late 1940s and 50s that is until now the
sudden rise of demagoguery authoritarian
style leaders and so-called populism in
the United States and around the world
for bodes a return to those earlier
periods the tactics of this strand of
politics are well trod a call for a
particular identity religious ethnic
racial national nationalistic a claim
that this identity is under threat
especially from quote foreigners and
immigrants fanciful ideas about possible
policies and hyperbolic claims of
achievements disregard to the truth so
that one can believe whatever one wishes
demonization of opponents legitimization
of private violence and a bundle of
other totalitarian strategies in the
United States President Trump is
deploying all of these methods he has
called for the jailing of his opponent
reminiscent of what happened to
presidential candidate Eugene Debs
indicated he might not accept the
election results if he lost made claims
about the results of the popular vote in
the election false claims asserted that
the media regularly and deliberately
engage in purveying falsehoods and he's
repeatedly labeled them the enemies of
the people he has himself as counted by
The Washington Post engaged over 5,000
falsehoods and lies
exaggerated his own accomplishments the
foreigners and immigrants mocked and
ridiculed opponents approved of an
incited violence against journalists
shown disregard for the rule of law and
endorsed implicitly and even it's
explicitly violence towards certain
groups in a deep sense the only thing
that currently stands between full
authoritarianism in the United States
and where we are at the moment is the
rule of law which fortunately now
remains strong for the time being at any
rate as Professor Wu points out in his
essay the free speech in the free speech
century quote is the first amendment
obsolete
for now the ways in which censorship is
being manifest are taking
non-traditional forms and not official
assaults on freedom of speech and press
as any sophisticated observer knows
unofficial and private intolerance can
be just or even more sensorial than the
official varieties so there is little
comfort to be taken in where we stand at
the present moment in time if it were to
change however and become official how
would the jurisprudence fair I am NOT
optimistic it seems to me that if we
have learned anything in the last 100
years it is that in times of heightened
insecurity and fear which is especially
true in times of war the pervasive
unwillingness to tolerate dissent
opposition and nonconformity is almost
an irresistible force for judges perhaps
the fact that we have now lived long
enough with the modern jurisprudence of
free speech and press and have often
professed to be ashamed and embarrassed
by the fever pitch of intolerance and
it's devastatingly unjust consequences
in the to earlier low points in the
evolution of the First Amendment this
will be enough to resist now or in the
future some like my good friend and
colleague professor Fred shower of
courses
respondents here whose essay in the
free-speech century entitled every
possible use of language argues that the
extension of the First Amendment beyond
the core of political expression I for
example for commercial speech
jeopardizes its capacity to resist
censorship in periods of crisis but
besides the possibility that there may
actually be strength and greater
complexity I worried that every new era
of repression sees itself as unique in
its own way and therefore unbound by
prior teachings and lessons one thing
the court might do would be finally to
overrule several of the Court's
decisions that have defined the collapse
of the First Amendment and are widely
understood to be discredited but it not
have not been overruled after 100 years
it might be good to do some editing of
the jurisprudence of course speaking out
is the thing to do to help reduce the
slide into yet another deep pit of
censorship I believe there is an
important role for universities to play
in this process the academic mission is
compromised by becoming political but
the qualities of mind that characterized
that mission cannot survive in the world
or in a nation that loses respect for
truth in a profound sense and that falls
so far below the norms of civil public
discourse as to be dysfunctional this
becomes an existential and not a
political issue for the university small
things might be done to help I would
just note the recent establishment at
Columbia of the Knight Institute First
Amendment Institute which we launched
with the 50 million dollar endowment and
the mission of advancing research
teaching public education and more to
the point litigation on freedom speech
and press this is the result of a
collaboration between Alberto ibarguen
president of the knight Foundation and
me to lodge an a relatively secure an
independent institution namely a
university
an organization that will be engaged in
helping secure the First Amendment of
the last century in a meaningful role in
the society in this century for the past
century a benefit of what was
effectively a monopoly status for much
of the press was combined which combined
both wealth and a strong journalistic
ethos was that there would always be an
advocate with the desire and the
financial endurance to see through to
the end any challenge to government
abuse of power in today's world however
because of the effects of the internet
the wealth of the traditional media has
been depleted and the new media that is
the social media platforms while they
have abundant wealth lack the ethos our
hope is that the knight Institute will
be there to fill the gap it is now up
and running with one notable success in
obtaining a judicial injunction against
President Trump for excluding people
from his Twitter account on the basis of
the content of their comments this
decision of the district court is now on
appeal by the government I now want to
turn to the very complex and
controversial subject of the internet
and the potential for public
interventions or regulations and the
First Amendment I would start by
observing that there has been an
extraordinary change in the general view
of the Internet and its consequences for
the public forum at the beginning it was
hailed as an ideal form of what free
speech and press were intended to create
it would equalize opportunities to
participate in the forum allow instant
communication and universal access to
all knowledge and provide the first-ever
truly global communication system that
it would undermine the financial model
of the traditional press was regarded as
a boon for freedom of the press not a
threat today in contrast that is
difficult to find anyone willing to
extol its virtues instead there are
regular cries about the destruction of
the public mind citizens can choose to
avoid public issues altogether and do so
as a matter of practice
when citizens do choose to confront
public issues they tend to be highly
selective in what they encounter which
means they succumb to the natural human
in wish to be around only opinions that
reaffirm their own a practice which over
time tends to make a person more
intolerant towards and angry about
opposing views meanwhile we are now
keenly aware that the global
characteristics of the Internet make
Americans more vulnerable to propaganda
manipulation and falsehood proper
falsehoods propagated by foreign
governments and malicious actors exhibit
one of this risk materializing is the
consensus view of the United States
intelligence agencies that the Russian
government took the extraordinary step
of actively trying to influence the 2016
presidential election and to discredit
democracy finally there is one a deep
concern that the monopolistic status of
social media and search engines and
their remarkable user base gives these
for-profit companies undue control over
the distribution of information and
ideas however much they profess to be
neutral and exercising that power and to
an equal concern that the business model
of these companies relies on their being
able to control massive amounts of
personal data one of the things that is
most striking to me is how few actual
concrete proposals there are right now
for dealing with many of these issues I
put aside the privacy issue in the
free-speech century we have three essays
that together reveal just how vexing
these problems are and how novel when by
Professor Emily Bell of the Columbia
Journalism school Monica Picard who's
the head of policy management at
Facebook and Tim Wu who's at the
Columbia Law School and I noted his
essay earlier the outline of a policy
response to these problems again putting
aside the privacy issues will focus
largely I anticipate on warnings and
notations about information being out
inaccurate or missed
banning foreign government involvement
in elections will no doubt continue
although even this can become
complicated very quickly and certainly
there will be a need for a new framework
developed an international law for
illegal intrusions and highly aggressive
efforts to influence public opinion we
will need to draw red lines and indicate
appropriate national responses just like
the world has over centuries developed
with respect to traditional violations
of sovereignty such as with physical
invasions of territory but providing
more information about speakers and
their messages when they have been
designated as false or propaganda sneek
will be the heart of the first round of
remedies for the present concerns about
manipulation of public opinion given all
this here's how I would think here's all
about what I think we're where we stand
in one sense I'm not at all troubled by
thinking about creating some kind of
public regulatory oversight for the
development of these technology
companies the fact that it is too early
in our experience with this new
communications technology to weigh its
potential benefits and harms to our
public thought process and to devise
specific public interventions to enhance
the first and limit the second does not
seem to me automatically to foreclose
government or public involvement we have
been through this before in fact this is
more or less exactly the situation we
found ourselves in with broadcasting
beginning in the first half of the last
century with similar concerns as I
indicated in the first election the
response at the time and carried through
to this day was to create a government
agency with the general mandate to
figure out regulations that would serve
the quote public interest convenience
and necessity censorship as such was
explicitly prohibited and the FCC or
Federal Communications Commission did so
with regulations such as the Fairness
Doctrine requiring broadcasters to cover
public issues and to do so fairly
in representing different viewpoints on
those issues that system as I have noted
was upheld by the Supreme Court I know
that the conventional view on this is to
see the broadcast model is unique and an
appropriate precedent for this
application but I do not share that view
so from my interpretation of the First
Amendment there is a model readily
available in the existing First
Amendment jurisprudence the government
under continuous oversight by the courts
might be a partner with private industry
in the evolution of this new technology
of communication still with all that
said I would not be inclined to pursue
this course at this moment I think it is
still too early and we would benefit
from thinking through other alternative
approaches to dealing with the problems
we are beginning to perceive here it is
important to be reminded of the lesson I
take from the First Amendment experience
that we always tend to overrate the
risks with new technologies of
communication that also happened
centuries ago with the printing press
and it's also happened in the last
century with some regulations of films
and even of broadcasting the presence of
various competing views about what to do
here and how bad it is if nothing else
is proof in my mind of the benefit to be
gained from one watching how the tech
companies respond to criticisms about
their platforms to watching how citizens
themselves respond to the proliferation
of bad speech and three deeper research
and analysis of what we are actually
facing it can be helpful to step back
and take a comprehensive perspective on
what we have created remember for
example when the court declared that all
streets and parks had to be open to
speech without regard to viewpoint that
also enabled the Klan and the neo-nazis
to push their messages more effectively
than before it seems to me that there
are also many things we could Institute
or enhance that would be then beneficial
in themselves and also respond to
problems we pursue
now for example in my view one of the
greatest risks we are encountering today
is the financial undermining of the
traditional press we need different ways
of getting and receiving ideas and
information and we need as I have
suggested several times already
institutions which are more than the sum
of individual actors the print and
broadcast media are among the
institution's we need to fortify well I
know in the current state of American
politics this is an idea unlikely to
succeed I would greatly increase public
support for our public broadcasting
system and even provide such funding for
the press generally with any public
funding mechanism there are always risks
of providing leverage for censorship but
there are well-known ways to minimize
that risk and bring it to an acceptable
level in my view finally I would also
hope that universities would be prepared
to become greater participants in the
public forum about two-thirds of high
schools to graduates go on to some form
of higher education that number could be
much higher with more public funding how
we educate and train each new generation
in light of the changing nature of the
public forum will be important in many
ways it is by far our most important
social or political platform Civic
Platform meanwhile we need more and
better journalism schools and in public
education a curriculum that from an
early age develops in every new
generation a better understanding of
digital literacy which prepares our
citizens to be more intelligent and wise
consumers of news in an increasingly
complex online environment and we would
all benefit universities as well as the
public if universities became more
engaged with practical issues facing the
society and the world to this end we
have launched at Columbia an important
initiative called Columbia World
projects which commits the university to
work with outside partners in solving
significant societal problem
in limited time periods and finally I
would say all this provides yet another
reason why it would be good for the
court to articulate how the system of
knowledge preservation and development
which I set forth in the first lecture
also is part of the central meaning of
the First Amendment we should be focused
on the broad ways in which we advance
knowledge in art which has value
independent of our political culture yet
is also intimately connected to it
undergirds that in fact looking at all
this as a whole also makes us more aware
of the potential for a positive role of
the state since the system of knowledge
is significantly suffused with and
sustained by public funding National
Institutes of Health National Science
Foundation National endowments for the
Arts and Humanities are all signal
government funders we are in the early
development of these new media and still
very much finding our way the technology
companies themselves have evolved out of
a vision of simply providing a means a
platform for people to communicate along
the lines of a public utility the legal
upshot of this vision is reflected in
the early law absolving them of any
liability for harmful and the illegal
speech distributed on their platform
section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act of 1996 is the key point as
they have been transformed into a major
perhaps even dominant public forum in
the society in the world the more they
have come under enormous pressure to
limit speech from a free speech
perspective this is both good and bad
the more dominant and monopolistic their
control of public thought and discussion
becomes the more their restrictions on
speech effectively become the equivalent
of government censorship on the other
hand the First Amendment is often
absolutely dependent as I've said on the
private sphere being more restrictive
than the Constitution permits
all this produces a kind of paradox the
government is increasingly wary of the
power of these companies and we now see
it using soft power that is
congressional hearings which tech
executives are brought in to testify as
a kind of tacit regulation the tech
companies are clearly very worried about
an onset of regulation and negative
public reactions and our increasing
efforts to control speech on their
platforms but the more they do that the
more they are putting in jeopardy their
initial vision of neutrality and the
legal benefits of protections against
liability fundamentally we are on a
course where these technology companies
are moving inexorably to becoming
curators editors of information
knowledge and opinion however much they
resist going there the fact is that
algorithms are a form of human editing
but they are very limited as editors and
in the end algorithms will not be able
to do all we expect of these
institutions so now like to turn to the
enormous lee complex and important
issues surrounding the development of a
system of freedom of speech and press in
a new globalized world of course this is
a hugely difficult matter not least
because the views about this varies so
greatly around the world and because we
have no simple way of resolving these
differences of perspective but the fact
of increasing interdependence II driven
largely by markets and economic activity
trade foreign investment and so on
because of new global communications
technologies the movements of people
whether cause as I said by human
curiosity or the ambition for a better
life are very very real forces and so is
the fact that there are major problems
that have to be dealt with because of
these phenomena problems that require
collective action of some form because
they cannot be solved otherwise global
warming again
example that we are in a period of
rising hostility towards globalization
which not coincidentally is often being
expressed and manifest in social and
political movements that are also
threatening to freedom of speech impress
does not I think mean that these forces
of globalization globalization will be
reversed completely on the country it
seems to me this is more proof about the
overwhelming power and strength of the
processes of integration as with the
internet the swingin attitudes about
globalization from Pangloss II and
idealism a little more than a decade ago
to outright denunciation and pessimism
now from Davos to Detroit as one might
describe it has been dramatic meanwhile
the foundations of the world continued
to shift towards inner dependency and
the need for attending to a system of
freedom of expression to support it will
continue to grow in importance
I see the general problem as having two
dimensions one is that every individual
nation will have to decide for itself
how it will arrange for its citizens to
relate to the rest of the world both in
speaking to the world and in hearing
from it and my immediate interest at
this level is how to shape our thinking
about the First Amendment in the United
States in this regard the other
dimension is how we will evolve a global
set of norms about freedom of expression
in an important sense there will be a
dialogue among nations explicitly or
implicitly as each one grapples with its
own solutions and approaches in a deeper
sense there will be a serious question
over how much individual nations will be
prepared to give up or adjust their own
sovereignty over the realm of speech to
a more international or multinational
system we are building on an existing
foundation created in that seminal
period following the Second World War
when most of the current international
system was created article 19 of the
1947 Universal Declaration of human
provides a vigorous international
version of the first amendment to the US
Constitution declaring quote everyone
has the right to freedom of opinion and
expression this right includes freedom
to hold opinions without interference
and to seek receive and impart
information and ideas through any media
regardless of frontiers this is now
widely accepted as constituting
international law and it has been
embedded further in the International
Covenant on Civil and Political Rights
in 1966 and in various regional charters
around the world notably the American
inner American Convention on Human
Rights in 1969 so much always depends
upon our understanding understandings
about what we are trying to do and here
again we need a shift in our basic
mentality when the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights was drafted and signed
the world was trying to recover from two
devastating world wars and to reduce the
ways this might be repeated the idea of
human rights was thought about in that
context governments that denied basic
human rights to be sitted to its
citizens were believed to be more
inclined to be aggressive towards other
nations and thus to ignite yet another
conflagration respect for human rights
and free speech and press most
especially was thought to be important
to preserving peace through halting
dependencies of totalitarian regimes
this wrote logic still has relevance
today but there is a new reality that
brings into focus a whole new rationale
this new reality is globalization and
its issues and the new rationale for
freedom of speech and press is the need
for the capacity to solve these issues
and to advance knowledge so that the
world can be a good place to live it is
critically important that we envision
the international norm of freedom of
expression with this new purpose
in mind returned to an examination of
how the United States should think about
the First Amendment in light of the
modern world of globalization here - we
need to COO to begin to develop a new
mindset built on an awareness of how the
United States cannot continue to think
of itself in this area of free speech
and press as existing in isolation in a
bubble separated from the necessity of
developing global knowledge and public
opinion that does not necessarily mean
that justices should somehow become
liberal internationalists or think of
themselves as acting on behalf of world
citizens one can accept and embrace the
realities of a global system of
expression for addressing global
problems and still think about it solely
from the standpoint of what the First
Amendment must guarantee in order for
American citizens to be able to
participate effectively in that system
what is actually involved here is really
just an extension of what we went
through in the last century represented
most significantly by what the court did
in New York Times versus Sullivan which
imposed strong limits on what individual
states could do and had been doing since
the birth of the country in the ways of
protecting individual reputations at the
expense of open and free discussion as
the nation became more interconnected
with a national as opposed to a local
economy and expanding national
consciousness about issues like
segregation or discrimination the
environment and more and with the new
inherently national communications
technology again both contributing to
this new reality and enabling national
decision-making the court had to develop
national standards for free speech and
press the spirit of that necessity
pervades New York Times versus Sullivan
now this same process is happening on a
worldwide scale and we need in this
century to devise ways of coming to
terms with this change which of course
will be far more difficult since there
is not a quote Supreme Court to appeal
to for enforceable international
law with this in mind you can quickly
see that there are a host of very
specific and concrete areas and problems
that will have to be addressed over time
here are some of them with the reality
now that the the virtually anything said
on the internet will be instantaneously
transmitted around the world we will
have to decide what degree will we weigh
in in limiting free speech within the
United States the effects that of speech
outside the country this could be either
inciting violence or causing violent
reactions because of its burfi perceived
offensiveness prime illustration of this
example was in 2012 the publication on
youtube of a privately produced quote
film about the Prophet Muhammad which
led to riots in the Middle East how
should the classic classic hostile
audience doctrine developed in the
domestic context be applied here to
citizens might wish to participate in
helping foreign actors and their
political activities to what extent
should the principles develop for
protection of domestic political
activities apply abroad in humanitarian
law project versus holder a u.s.
activist group sought to provide legal
assistance to the Turkish PPK which in
federal laws designated a foreign
terrorist organization and thus any
material support to it is prohibited the
Supreme Court expressing deference to
Congress and the executive branches over
matters involving foreign policy held
that a different minimal standard of
protection should be applied in such
cases whatever one thinks about the
particular circumstances in this case
the lowered First Amendment protections
for speech activity outside the United
States seem badly out of step with the
need for a global public forum this will
have to be reviewed and the gap closed
the corollary problem is to what extent
can foreign actors government's
organizations and individuals be
prohibited and prevented from
participating in the US public forum
in the United States now of course there
is heightened concern as I indicated
earlier about Russian government
meddling in the 2016 election this
involved hacking into the Democratic
National Committee computer stealing
emails and publishing those emails
through WikiLeaks using fake accounts to
distribute false information and
inflammatory opinions and hacking into
the voting systems in several states the
US intelligence community has warned
that these actions have taken the
general spying regime to a completely
new level perhaps even threatening
American democracy
currently foreign states are forbidden
from using money to influence our
elections and anyone who represents a
foreign government in the US political
system must must register with the
foreign with the federal government and
of course hacking computers is illegal
but what quotes speech by foreign
governments and actors should be
prohibited as well a related problem is
when cable operators for example which
are generally regulated because of their
natural monopolies thetas refused to
allow foreign state broadcasters such as
al-jazeera or RT or RT to distribute
their content to cable customers should
this be allowed and the public deprived
of access to foreign media because those
media are regarded as offensive or
propagandistic or mouthpieces a bad act
state actors a major point of contention
for this new global system is the border
traditionally as with foreign policy the
courts have been extremely deferential
to the government in deciding how to
admit and deny entrance to foreigners
and how to treat US citizens the recent
so-called travel ban of the Trump
administration is an example the
purported rationale was national
security but it was challenged on the
grounds that it represented invidious
religious discrimination against Muslims
academic institutions filed amicus
briefs providing the courts with
information about the
Horton's of the free movement of
students and scholars to research and
education but the academic institutions
stopped short of claiming the ban
violated the First Amendment another
example would be a policy reportedly
under consideration by the
administration to deny visas to Chinese
nationals the study and work at
universities in the United States as a
way purportedly of protecting US
intellectual and research property from
being stolen if we envision the First
Amendment is protecting the system of
knowledge production I recommended
earlier a key component of which is the
exchange of ideas through interactions
with scholars and students
internationally a strong First Amendment
interest can be weighed in the balance
here there are many other examples of
border decisions that evoke these large
questions visa denies to foreign
citizens on the basis of viewpoints
special visas required a foreign media
to operate within the United States and
restrictions on US citizens leaving and
coming back to the country based on
their beliefs and expressive activities
still another illustration is whether
the US courts will or should enforce
judgments against US citizens obtained
in foreign courts involving restrictions
on speech that would not be permitted
under First Amendment law I do not have
the time obviously to resolve each of
these problems but I would suggest
several recommendations for how we the
court should approach solving them here
as always everything should start with
an open recognition of what we are
trying to do and why the key to his
acknowledged I think the key is to
acknowledge that we now have an interest
under the First Amendment in building a
framework of general principles and
specific doctrines that will enable US
citizens to participate in the global
public forum and to receive and hear
voices from around the world this also
applies that the system of
growing knowledge - this means of
necessity that we must at the very least
reduce the deference paid to government
actions in the areas of foreign policy
and foreign affairs and immigration than
customs 3 there is a long tradition in
comparative law of taking note of legal
doctrines and decisions in other
countries today's world requires that
our courts at the very least be
conscious of how their decisions will be
received abroad and realized that we
have an interest in other nations
becoming more protective of speech and
press and therefore in understanding
what we are doing trying to do and why
we need to think hard about how we speak
to them as well as ourselves professor
Sarah Cleveland has an essay in the free
speech century on this in that process
of persuasion we should recognize and
openly address the facts of our own
history and how it has been marred by
bad decisions we did not come to where
we are either quickly or in a straight
line we have a century of experience and
it is important to draw on its parts
good and bad and lastly in this realm
enlarging the vision of the first
amendment from serving democracy to the
development of knowledge and the myriad
benefits of that will be better received
in a world which has many other forms of
government the idea of freedom of speech
serving the Madisonian conception of
citizens sovereignty which is the New
York Times versus Sullivan theory and
Michael John is necessarily limited on
the world stage the advancement is
knowledge as far more compatible with
the reality of multiple systems of
government lastly let me turn to the
massive problem of developing global
norms on free speech and press this can
occur at two levels
just as with changes within the United
States it can be at the within each
nation but it can also be at the
regional and global level
we have international institutions that
are involved in this these are matters
we should inquire into I could speak
about strengthening these international
institutions in Europe and regional
institutions in Europe Latin America and
Africa or about using other areas of
international agreements and mechanisms
to enforce free speech and press
standards the particular interest to me
has been using the WTO and international
trade law and foreign direct investment
treaties as a way to get greater free
speech and press rights around the world
we could talk about preserving the
complex governance structure of the
internet that's so crucial and that it
not be vulcanized or about how to expand
the use of laws in nations with strong
free speech and press cultures to
restrict visas or freeze financial
assets of leaders of countries that
violate free speech and Free Press or
about how these nations could put more
pressure on other countries that violate
these norms as in the recent Khashoggi
case or about exploring this is very
important the periods in every
civilization where there was respect for
tolerance and openness of expression and
the development of knowledge so that
every nation can find for itself a model
to build on for today rather than
creating a false sense that these
freedoms and values are really just
American or Western notions I'd like to
focus though for just a moment on what
seemed to me to be two very important
factors in the development of free
speech norms in the coming century one
is an overarching observation the other
is tactical the first has to do with
China we all know that China is well on
its way to becoming a global superpower
and because of that what it becomes will
have a profound influence on our world
but China's evolution into a world
superpower is more than an economic and
political reality China is also creating
a bundle of values that will affect the
rest of the world or at least contend
for influence
it is important that we understand in
this regard that among those values is a
view of freedom of expression and
knowledge that is strikingly at odds
with that of the First Amendment and
with Western enlightenment and liberal
values this has to be taken very
seriously in fact it may be said that
there are now two conflicting
philosophies about free spray a speech
and press emergent in the world today
each contending for influence and
ultimate dominance any serious
discussion about the future of freedom
of expression in the world in this
century must start with this contest of
perspectives until recently the general
view among sophisticated observers of
China has been either of two
possibilities would unfold one view was
that the leadership of China realized
that once the period of modern
development of the economy and social
system was reached the country would
have necessity in choice become more
open in terms of free expression this
would follow the course of history of
other developed nations and would be
consistent with the rising expectations
of its increasingly educated and
traveled population the other view is
darker but thought to be equally
favorable to an evolution towards
greater openness namely that modern
China had been created out of an
inherent contradiction an open market
economy and a closed authoritarian
political regime that must at some point
implode and when that happened the
argument goes the forces of openness
were more likely to emerge victorious
today neither of these theories seems
any longer descriptive of reality as
China has become more and more
successful economically it has become
more and more confident in its overall
system which includes rising levels of
repression of dissent and general
censorship in fact in China today there
is now a much more direct and open
challenge to the view about freedom of
speech and press that has defined the
United States the challenge argues that
the US political
and social system will itself implode
because of the extreme positions we had
taken under the First Amendment by the
new Chinese view protecting extremists
speech allowing radical dissent to
flourish denying protections to the
government against attacks and
falsehoods and so on all have
contributed to the steady decline in
social and political cohesion and
necessary trust in the government and
the state for this view the election of
Donald Trump is proof of theory how
should we think about this challenge one
can start by understanding whether we
are what we are facing today and in
other democracies that are turning
illiberal is a sign of the failure of
the free speech experiment or a downward
cycle that is inevitable given our
understanding of human nature and when
we know we must continually work against
them minimize by creating strong and
enduring institutions built on the idea
of open and free inquiry not
surprisingly I believe the latter but we
cannot prove these ideas except for the
quality of life we witness over the long
term we can however make our case more
effectively than we have looked at from
the perspective of 100 years of the
First Amendment what we see today in the
u.s. is in a profound sense not
surprising at all nor proof of a failure
of the interpretations we have given to
the First Amendment every society will
face these political and intellectual
recessions periodically just like
economic recessions the success of a
nation over time will be in its acquired
capacity to recognize the sources and to
minimize the effects of these
regressions for us to do that and to
play a more effective role in the world
stage and advocate for a more robust
principle of free speech and Free Press
we have to change ourselves
beginning with how we organize
knowledge and expertise I know this from
my own work in the First Amendment as I
have indicated I came of age as a
scholar in the period of this last
century in which the tectonic plates of
free speech came together to form a
single national system of principles and
doctrines defining free speech and press
my scholarly expertise encompassed that
range but in the new globalized and
interconnected world
I know too little about the developments
across the world outside of the United
States in my field of law I took the
United States and the rest of the world
was assigned to those who did
international law and international
human rights given current realities of
the world were heading into that
separation of knowledge will not work we
all need to know more than our fields
have led us to know in the last decade I
have tried to change this for myself and
my field at Columbia established the
project on global freedom of expression
one of its functions is to do something
quite simple namely collect in one place
on a website all of the decisions about
free speech and press in nations around
the world we also give special
prominence to that is those decisions
that refer to international norms the
idea is that over time a long time to be
sure we will create more of a sense of
community of common law around these
issues that exist today since courts and
commentators can easily look in one
place and see what is happening there
they can make comparisons and materials
can be assembled for courses to educate
the next generation of students such
that their knowledge will not be as
limited as mine and so that they can
apply that knowledge both in their
professional lives and in the way they
exercise their rights and duties as
citizens this is basically what many law
professors did in the United States in
the last century in various areas of
common law contracts and torts and so on
when for the first time they collect the
decisions in individual states and then
wrote treatises about the emerging quote
common law they were helping to
from scratch by bringing together these
formerly separate and discrete cases
they created something new a common and
shared effort and a zeitgeist for seeing
everything as a whole rather than as
discrete parts in this next century
scene the development of free speech and
press around the world as a whole is the
vision we must seek then in such a world
we would all know about recent cases
such as Okuda versus Kenya in 2017 in
which the High Court of Kenya held that
criminal defamation laws were
unconstitutional or Primedia
broadcasting vs. Speaker of the National
Assembly 2016 in which the Supreme Court
of Appeal of South Africa struck down
Parliament's policies prohibiting
broadcasting of incidents in
parliamentary sessions or olestra vs.
Mexican industry of musical property in
which the Mexican Supreme Court of
Justice struck down a government agency
suspension of public asset access to a
particular website or North Korea tech
dot-org case in which a South Korean
Court of Appeals held that web sites
could be blocked only in exceptional
circumstances and that blocking of a
named website of the named web site by
the South Korean intelligence services a
newly limited the Korean public's right
to know and even that foreign operators
North Korea Tech org was operated from
the UK have standing in Korea by
extension of the right to freedom of
expression of Koreans or the decision of
the Kerala High Court in India to
dismiss a petition claiming that a
magazine cover depicting a woman
breastfeeding her child was obscene and
in violation of laws that protect women
and children or the case of tewfick soft
Inc in which the basic court and the
Constitutional Court of Montenegro for
the first time recognized that states
have positive obligations to protect
journalists from attacks and threats on
their life or the very very recent
decision of the Supreme
Court of Brazil to protect the rights of
university students and faculty to
express political views saying memorably
that quote the only force that must
enter universities is the force of ideas
and many many other judicial decisions
that extend and apply the globally
emerging principles of freedom of speech
and the freedom of the press the first
100 years of free speech in the United
States is instructive as an experiment
in the evolution of human values the
broad subject of the Tanner lectures at
this point it is a jurisprudential
beehive of cases opinions and doctrines
that bring a kind of order to a realm of
human activity and its relationship with
the state given its starting premises
about human nature and government what
it has aimed for is nothing short of
wondrous it asks of as something deeply
counterintuitive against the grain of
our inclinations all in the name of
sheltering our quest for knowledge and
of realizing our democratic choice for
self-government it has itself not always
succeeded by its own terms and now it is
being tested again by new threats
arising from the natural quote logic as
Holmes described a persecution by a
transformative technology of
communications and by a shrinking world
that needs all the discussion and
understanding it can muster there is
nothing simple about any of this and it
has been one of my purposes in these
lectures to highlight some of the key
complexities at the same time our
ignorant about critical elements of what
needs to be done now will make things
harder than they should be to sort out
the hope is that after a century of free
speech we will be able to learn from our
experience and to do even better in this
next century thank you
[Applause]